sports and we loved it and i bet a lot
of us grew up playing those slot cars
and then came along the remote control
cars and now as you can imagine they
make money racing those rc cars it's a
full-blown sport kevin martin has more
on the rc racers making a pit stop at
the south point this week
as a kid you might have raced a remote
control car in your driveway every boy
has to have an arson car if they're
passionate about it they progress just
like all things and in terms of racing
remote control cars if you're passionate
and dedicated you progress to this
it's the largest remote control car race
running nitro electric eight scale and
fifth scale cars on off road tracks just
as technical as a real car and ryan
mayfield has mastered it he is a 27-time
u.s national champion and two-time world
champion it's just time hours and hours
and hours of practicing preparing the
vehicles at home and just you know
repetition doing the same thing as much
as possible and there's a lot more to it
than you may think you're racing a car
that is that you're not in so you're
racing it forward you're racing it
backwards you're racing side to side and
you have to know the direction that you
need to go over the years remote control
car racing has absolutely exploded in
popularity when i was young we had 100
entries my first race and over the past
23 years has turned into
now we have like over a thousand like
1100 entries and while it is no doubt
male dominated women like rhonda drake
are proving they can race with the best
when people come to me and tell me
they're a huge fan it like i have to sit
back and like oh my god wow and over the
next couple of days thousands of drivers
from all over the country will be
competing here in vegas in the dirt
silver state indoor championships the
track conditions get really rough so
it's not for
the novice driver it's for a really
seasoned driver
kevin martin live local now